here we go are you ready for a big day
and evening of baseball between the blue
jays and the red sox at fenway park as
they make up the game that was postponed
from last week and don't look now but
i'm sure you know this already if you're
a follower of the blue jays they are
tied with the new york yankees for
second place in the american legion
chadley's own three in era of 771. well
he threw four shutout innings against
toronto earlier this year he's looking
for his first win hopefully it's today
when he leads off as a 404 on base
percentage second highest in the
american league going to roll over that
one to peraza and that's a fast out
here's ronnie tellez 247 with six home
runs feels like all of those have been
hit against the red side and he's going
to slap that one in the center field for
a single yeah he's got a five-game
hitting streak now with that base hit
he's swung on and missed and he made a
good pitch to strike out hernandez
tanner rorack is making his seventh
start going for his third win while they
have been victors in his last four
outings and five of his six games
started the only loss was against the
boston red sox
the 3-2 fastball swing and a miss chased
out of the zone
rafael divers and he's in swing mode
early
and got him to chase a curveball and the
tag applied by janssen at back-to-back
strikeouts to start the day for rohar
xander bogarts and in limited bats it
has been a one-sided match-up between
these two advantage bogarts in the 3-2
pitch right down the middle strike three
called bogarts goes down looking and how
about the start this afternoon at fenway
for tanner
travis shaw the left-handed batter yeah
this has always been a tough time of the
day for hitters and you see that
hitter's background they have that black
tarp over the seats
travis shaw sends the ball to deep
center field and gone
no trouble for him to see the ball
number four on the season for sean the
blue jays take the lead
so a two out base runner danny jansen
number nine hitting catcher
jansen gets a hold of one he hits it a
long way and gone
a two-run shot for jensen up above the
monster and it is three to nothing
a home run to travis shaw followed up by
a costly walk
exclamation point danny jansen
and a two run home run
down to third is plucky with two away
jarrow munoz sitting at 250.
high fly ball left field that's deep
turning around guriel that one's going
to get out of here it's a home run gyro
munoz indeed swinging a good bat there
and a two run shot
make this a 3-2 game randall grichik
leads off the third
as grichik lines the ball to left field
this is going to get off the monster
just above the scoreboard randall's
trying for two and is in there
a single for rowdy and the blue jays are
in business here in the third with
runners on the corners and nobody out
it's sharply down to third the red sox
will try to turn two
and they will the run will come in to
score no rbi for hernandez and it's four
to two no rbi for tay oscar but he gets
that run in from third base with less
than two out
jeffrey springs just got up the lefty
well his last start against the
nationals for godly he was given eight
runs to work with but he couldn't get
through the fifth inning he never did
qualify for red sox would win that game
nine to five and down he goes hacking
interesting exchange between innings
wenecke obviously taking godly out of
the game he can't believe it not happy
about it and he'll storm his way down to
the dugout steps and probably up to the
clubhouse
but that's going to be the afternoon
jeffrey springs gets set to throw his
first pitch to kevin vigil and it's a
little check swing liner over the leap
of denver's and into left field an
excuse me base hit for kevin biggio on
the first pitch of the fifth inning
biggio goes to third and another run
just 90 feet away for the blue jays with
one out in the fifth
as he lifts a fly ball down the left
field line and back on the edge of the
track munoz will make the catch biggio
will tag and slide in with the fifth run
of the ball game for the blue jays
here's peraza now fly to left his first
time up hitless in his last 14 at bats
and when socked into center field richik
on his horse turning around that thumps
into the bottom of the wall
munoz rounding hard he's going to try
and score it he will and peraza will
pick up the rbi and that makes it a 5-3
game red sox with a threat here they
already have a run in runners at first
and third one gone for devers in the
dirt it squirts underneath and goes to
the backstop here comes the run
and down to second verdugo it's five to
four
on a wild one
and the blue jays have loaded the bases
with nobody out a big opportunity for
joe panic he has walked and scored and
grounded out
and panic hits it through the right side
for a base hit everybody moves up 90
feet and the blue jays had a run base is
still loaded randall critic the hitter
swinging a broken battle roller towards
the hole out of the reach of bogarts
into left field a base hit one run is in
here comes a second run shaw will score
standing up and the blue jays tally a
pair and build an 8-4 lead these red sox
will go to the bullpen again stock
coming on
and that one stroked into center field
backing up jackie bradley junior leaping
and he caught it
he caught it with an acrobatic play on
the warning track
saving two runs in the process
so red sox have man at first and third
with nobody out
rips that one he's got another hit down
the line
plawecki will score easily
jackie bradley to third as he loses the
helmet it's a double for munoz and the
red sox get a little closer that'll make
it eight to five
another base in in the center field one
run is in bradley scores munoz to third
eight to six second hit today for chavis
here's peraza a.j cole out of their pen
runners at first and third again nobody
out that one hits softly maybe two
they'll try and turn it but won't
they're going to hang on to it at second
base and in to score another run is
munoz blue jays have an 8-7 lead over
the red sox anthony bass is out of the
pin trying to lock it up or toronto now
with two down the blue jays and out away
from a victory it is jackie bradley jr
again the 3-2
and a bouncer over him but right
in the right spot out at second
to make the play and end the game
and they have taken games one and two
and they've got a seven eight affair
still in front of them